[Music]
you know the uh mouthwash listerine no
you never heard of it
you must be a halley
for um for 2.1 million
would you buy royalties that pay out
114k a year forever
forever yeah
so two for 2.4 million right
2.1 million 2.1 at my age hell yeah
and you get 140k a year you get you get
114k a year because they are selling a
percentage of royalties
uh for 2.1 million you can buy in
and the interest that has been paid out
in the past for the owner of that uh
percentage was about 114 000 per year
wow so it takes 20 years to get your
money back yeah
yeah it would take about 18 right but
then afterwards the next one sailing
yeah you're so far uh one bitter has
offered one million but nobody's uh as
of now
bought that royalty right i think you
can get it at one five bar okay i think
you can get a one to five ball them a
little bit
yeah so i guess like what happened is
when uh
after taxes
back in 1881 the guy who invented it his
name is dr jj lawrence when he sold uh
the company he added like a clause in
the sale where like you you had to like
make a certain amount of uh royalties
available for public purchase
so they have to like now there's another
piece going on for sale they have to
sell it wow um
yeah is that a good idea people want to
buy listerine but the thing is the offer
is not that lucrative i guess because
people are like nah
i gotta wait 20 years yeah that's so
long yeah it is a long time but i mean
if you got that laying around for your
kids that'd be kind of nice yeah it's
long-term money [ __ ] but that's also
assuming that listerine never gets like
yeah
oh that's not true it is listerine but
it's like the top brand yeah who else
who else it's scope i mean you know no
again colgate they got all these
competitors now yeah but who's gonna
battle with listerine though they're
like the one
and he got all these organic fools like
[ __ ] kills and [ __ ] or whatever like
all these other side kills
1881 that shit's been around like you
guys remember the brown one have you
guys ever used the brownless string oh
yeah yeah yeah that's the oh jesus
my daddy sees that [ __ ] and i'll be like
what the [ __ ] is wrong it tastes like
[ __ ] it does like get the mints the
flavor i don't know that's the one that
that's my dad only got that one that
brown one it's ass flavored yeah
it's 1881 ass
nobody trusts brown water you know i
mean just on branding looks just like
but it does look kind of gold though you
know yeah that's true so there's only
one royalty
exchange of
apparently at this moment only one
person can buy that the other ones are
being spoken for i guess oh you mean
like i'm sorry can they break that up
they break it up yeah i don't know can
we all say like yo we'll take 100k yeah
it seems like you can't otherwise it
probably would have been some offers but
one million i think is the highest offer
right now
according to this that's so weird that's
such a weird like i know
one million is so worth it though to get
a hundred because it only takes ten
years yeah yeah and it's guaranteed as
long as listening doesn't fall off the
map i mean interestingly though i mean
if you if this was kodak doing that
remember kodak was around for hundreds
of years and in like one year instagram
put it out of business [ __ ] yeah
definitely really something like that
kodak i thought they'd been dead
no it was like uh i literally was like
the quickest that a company was like i
thought digital cameras took them out
yeah yeah like canon yeah yeah i think
they were still hanging in there
because they had their own line yeah
they make they make cameras too fuji
film they're little you know yeah how
they take uh well she could actually
disposable films on its way back i don't
know why
so many people are back on yeah
coachella saw people because they're
like
cameras i'm like dude you guys are never
getting that developed like you don't
even know where to go together this [ __ ]
is so out of the way thrift season [ __ ]
and get it developed
they'll get pissed at you do they still
gotta save on
you gotta go to save you save on because
this markets that used to develop them
aren't there nobody that's so true you
can't do it at cvs it's walgreens now i
think you go to walmart and get it done
all greens and walmart you can get your
film all right well as long as those
stores exist man they do so you're not
trying to buy everything you're not
trying to buy listerine
royalties how do you think they could
develop i'd rather get a [ __ ]
cryptocurrency dude
if i had to choose one
it might have to be a
v05
hair gel or
hot water all right if you guys could
invest
l.a looks if you could invest in a chop
in a in a [ __ ] household product yeah
and you feel like yo if i get this man
i'm set which one would you give me
this one's getting l.a looks do you
remember that one sounds like what they
say right before the freaking
it's the
gel that all the mexican kids at my
school shake challenge what they say
right before the music
it's a gel that like you put it and it
sticks up it's called muffled what
you're talking about is that strong yeah
but i don't know if it's it's definitely
not a name brand anymore like at least
nowadays
looks la looks like fire they still got
l.a looks nah hell no i think i'm about
to go with clorox actually
poro i can't beat bleach man
that's true that's important
yeah like a i would i would i would do
bounce
bounce oh the bounce sheets
tied bounce no no the [ __ ]
paper towel dude
oh bounty
bounties
got the wrong styles
like sir you're at the wrong building
they're down the street
that's a laundry detergent i would do
big bro big lighters that was gonna be
oh yeah that was going to be around
interesting yeah big lighters those will
just be around yeah but people don't
smoke as much no more yeah you need
lighters for like candles and like
hawaiian bonfires
yeah for the people for the hipsters
burning rosemary to bless their houses
yeah
so like if listerine was to lose value
in the future what do you think could
possibly take them down yeah what's the
technology big lighters bro
take them out
they figure out that lighting your
breath makes it
neutralize them bits coming for yourself
i think it's skull scopes one of them
and also generics i don't [ __ ] take
score
and it has like the better coconut oil
in it ew coconut oil
wow you guys ever did that oil if you
put a coconut oil in like every squish
oil and then you rinse your mouth and
then and your breath smells good
uh yeah it smells like coconut i would
want to first know if listerine has any
exclusives with other companies like
where like
every dentist has to use it or something
oh
there's three mafia
like four seasons like four they only
distribute to four seasons and like so
they're already locked in on the right
coca-cola's in specific places pepsi is
with like all college campuses too
or also i also want to know if some of
the other brands are really just
listerine repackaged yeah like if scope
is like realistic yeah like how a lot of
batteries are the same battery it's just
a different brand really oh
wow yeah that's [ __ ] yeah because you
really think there's that many different
battery factories it's like they're just
making the batteries here yeah i like
that
the carousel and energizer's the same
[ __ ] bro i don't know about
those two but i know there's a bunch
that are the same it's just the tape is
different huh
the same battery and then they wrap
different tape on it we gotta look up
the companies that actually do that and
what they are
i i believe that's the loophole oh
what's one company producing 10
companies
yeah cause some of them will read like
this water is bottled by a niagara falls
really oh it's niagara falls
but it's like another brand it was like
[ __ ] tastes like arrowhead yeah like
that exactly it should taste like
aquafina
this is the only trusted water bottle
that uh
is delicious they're going solid
i mean anything and they don't like
evian i [ __ ] hate everything
i like their bottles yeah it looks cool
but like what's your favorite
water
i hate imagining the very real truth
that there is a vat
at some point yeah
you know what a vat of listerine is
probably clean as hell it's listerine
that's what that's what makes it an
interesting choice is that it doesn't
have an opponent
uh virtually in the future that could be
a digital thing to take it out because
most things get taken out by digital
things you need a listerine nft there's
like technology that like
like lasers your teeth clean uv like it
yeah like
but isn't it for like stinky breath too
or is it like killing the bacteria well
that's another thing uh it was sort of
wasn't it like low-key debunked that it
doesn't really exactly people said like
it kills your good germs in your mouth
too so it's also like not that good for
you but then again it's like this
happens every like five years
some people come out with this like
groundbreaking study but in reality it's
just like propagandist i feel like when
i gargle with listerine when i'm when
i'm sick when i gargle that [ __ ]
i i heal faster
my when i get tonsillitis or like the
[ __ ] yeah
my danglers get [ __ ] inflamed you
probably kill the bacteria back there
yeah i do like a good listener but now i
just use salt and water because i never
buy listerine
like way cleaner after i do a splash of
mouthwash yeah i feel like i'm like oh
i'm on top of my [ __ ] today yeah i'm
ready to go to sleep so it's like you
can't drink water or eat anything right
after it's like or during yeah
that's the biggest issue
i like taking a snack while i brush my
teeth it takes so long
i'm gonna get through this man three
minutes gonna brush your teeth yeah it
is it is interesting because it doesn't
uh yeah you're right it like doesn't
really it's not necessary yeah it's but
also is it though it feels good though
no dentist will tell you
right like what do dentists think about
this there's always that one dentist
that doesn't agree
yeah and who are these dentists four out
of five you know what the [ __ ] are these
people and who's the one guy that's
what's up that's it yeah yeah he doesn't
want to work with anybody on that
apparently it's like they send out a
survey to dentists and like it depends
on who replies and they cherry-pick
their replies oh yeah yeah yeah
goddammit yeah so like if they sent out
a survey to a hundred dentists and ten
reply and only four out of the ten
are like positive they'll do a four out
of five because they're technically not
lying yeah so like four out of five of
the 100 agree right right but yeah like
that's like an extra fraction afterwards
yeah
and i like
like i was just they agree on this yeah
okay
because they're not yeah it's not
technically an illegal statement the
question is have you heard of listerie
[Music]
you